- Alright, I always like to end the show
with something happy and uplifting.
This is 'What I'm Liking.'
(upbeat sound effect)
Earlier this hour, we met
Craig, a music teacher
who had a major impact on
his former student, Talia.
She's now starring in
'Wicked' on Broadway.
(imitates air horn)
Music teachers make a difference, y'all.
It did in my life as well.
But now I want you to meet Katy Dane.
She's a middle school music teacher
who was recently named
Music Educator of the Year
by the National Association
for Music Education
and the Barbershop Harmony Society.
She's also a fellow Texan,
(imitates air horn)
and we have her on the line right now
watching on CBS, Austin.
What's up, how you doing, Katy?
(audience cheering)
- Hi Kelly.
- Oh my gosh.
Your choir room right now is
just taking me back, ma'am.
That's amazing.
- This is (indistinct), right?
- I mean, I don't know
we had all those trophies
but, yeah, look like
that, but congratulations.
I think you have more jobs than I do.
Can you tell everybody what you do?
- So I teach at Benold Middle School
and I teach sixth through eighth
grade orchestra and choir.
And then I also direct
two a cappella groups
and one of them is A Cappella Unlimited
and that's through Sweet
Adelines International
and I'm on the regional
education team for that.
And then I also direct a
a cappella Texas chorus,
Barbershop Chorus
and that's with Barbershop
Harmony Society.
And I'm on the Southwestern District Board
for that in vocal performance and music.
And then the other one
I do is Sing! Texas.
And we do promotional
music and conferences,
concerts for students all the way,
sixth grade through twelfth grade
in collegiate a cappella
and help them with kind
of educational outreach
and that kind of thing.
- Oh my gosh, you're doing all the things.
(audience applauding)
I love it.
I heard that you actually didn't even know
that you were nominated for this award.
- No, it was totally a surprise to me.
So it happened in early February
and our Vice Principal came into the room
and kind of was a big storm
and she said, "we have
to evacuate the building.
We have to get out."
And I thought it was some
sort of drill or something.
And then everyone went outside
and flew open in the door
and there were about 150 people
waiting in the parking lot outside.
Ton of my students from
mixed choir and orchestra,
school board members, the
Principal Fine Arts Director
and I pan across
and I see my parents had
flown in from Iowa, cousin,
my sister from New York, people
from DC, Nashville had come
every which way and crossed paths.
And right in that moment is
when they presented the award.
- That is such a special way to do it.
I love it so much.
(audience applauding)
And well deserved.
Take it from a kid who
really like my junior-
literally my middle school
Choir Director changed my life.
So she really is the one who pushed me,
she took no crap from me being lazy.
She pushed me and it was awesome.
It made me have the work ethic I have now
which is why we both have a billion jobs.
But thank you, Katy.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(ding)
It's an amazing thing, y'all,
what teachers do for children.
Thank you so much.
And that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor ultimate
overachievers, just like you ma'am
so they're gonna write
you a cheque for $1,000
just cause you're cool.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
Thank you so much, Katy.